[Music]
today's upset election in Alabama
Tuesday's upset election in Alabama has
given Democrats a rosy vision of a
return to glory and I understand that
and that's led a passel of pundits
predicting doom utter doom for the GOP
in 2018 you're watching this 170 year
old institution swiftly marching itself
toward destruction because can i devided
really more than a divided but an
internally competitive and eternally
angry combative republican party can't
can it win in 2018 and 2020 right now in
the Republican Party there are people
who are trying to record recruit similar
types of candidates in Senate races
around the country this is a recipe for
disasters well here's a larger issue for
the GOP and if we think about this
really carefully Mitch McConnell is
really smart and wily in so many ways so
experienced but is he looking to kind of
in some ways exploit the embarrassment
in Alabama to maybe knock out viable
populist candidates elsewhere there no
Roy Moore's but their populist so they
kind of conflate the two I'm thinking of
people like Kelly ward in Arizona Danny
Tarkanian New Mexico dime in Nevada so
you got it yeah think about this it this
is where the populist need to be careful
and smart because it's not enough to
have just a few national figures support
you no no you need money and you need
some allies within the mainstream GOP to
survive just like President Trump did
you know Kelly Ward remember tried and
failed to beat McCain but I'm telling
you she's a much better candidate now
than she was then so trying to tag her
as far right as the New York Times
attempted to do today is absurd should
be a fine general election candidate and
the party needs more strong smart women
joining me meet me now to discuss this
exclusively is RNC chairwoman Rhonda
McDaniel she huddled up with President
Trump today and this is her first
interview since the election in Alabama
Ronna great to see oh how are you oh
great to be here merry merry Christmas
up what's going on here the Alabama race
was a real
the Republicans no doubt about it but
for for the Republicans to extrapolate
that and say okay any populist candidate
in a place like Arizona specifically
Kelly Ward for Jeff Flake seat well no
you can't do that because it's just
gonna be another ROI more is that fair
yeah that's not fair Alabama's unique
special elections and in and of
themselves are unique you can't
extrapolate anything from them that's
going to be a bellwether in 2018 you'll
leave one candidate on the ballot so
many different circumstances that go
into each special election I do think
there are some lessons candidates do
matter
you do need good candidates we need to
let the voters make that decision the
voters don't love Washington coming in
and saying this is more common it should
be we don't have that we know that we
learned that with President Trump voters
want to decide their own fate and who
their nominee is gonna be and then we
are gonna have to work together as a
party we need to be swimming in the same
direction if we're gonna win these
elections Newt Gingrich wrote a piece in
Fox News Today Fox news.com and he it
was like I have a stark warning for the
Republicans he said Republicans must
pass tax cuts this year continue the
economic growth and they need to spend
January he said developing a new
strategy capable of changing current
patterns and maximizing their chances to
keep the house they have to increase
their Senate Majority by five or six he
says and so they'll be strong enough to
really hold that majority in 2020 when
those numbers going to look more
difficult do you agree with that
analysis yeah I think newts right on and
the RNC is right on track to do all
those things we want raise record money
we just announced a new record in
November we're already investing in
battleground states we're already in 18
states our data
nobody compete with can compete with our
data our ground game we have more people
on the ground than ever before and we're
also doing outreach to communities that
we haven't been in before we have to
start showing up and having a
conversation and talking about the
things we have in common but I think
newts absolutely right we're going to
compete for those House seats we've got
to keep the majority and there's a lot
of competitive Senate seats the map
looks good for us what did the president
say if you can share some of his
thoughts today that that are not private
what was his mood like what was he you
know he's great we talked about 2018
today
had the Christmas party at the white
house date a lot of RNC members at the
White House but he's jovial he's ready
for 2018 he's always looking to help
people's lives be better and he's and
he's focused on tax cuts we need to pass
tax cuts we just put up a website
paycheck president calm he's for
increasing wages getting more jobs and
sending more money home in people's
paychecks
well that RNC official that quit for the
ROI more support was that RNC official
looking back on it right but you guys
shouldn't have supported Roy Moore in
the end yeah we we had one out of a
hundred and fifty-eight overwhelmingly
the RNC members understand our role at
the RNC is to be the political arm of
the White House and the Alabama members
wanted to keep that seat and they
understand the slim majorities we had in
the Senate we always said Lott Alabama
decide we knew these allegations were
deeply concerning they were incredibly
troubling but at the end of the day
Alabamans maybe well the president said
look I know people a lot of Republicans
are glad he's not here but just for my
agenda I wish we had that seat that
that's a pragmatic way of looking at it
and I know it horrifies a lot of
Republicans but that is true losing that
seat is a blow to the Republican Party
yeah he always said these allegations
are incredibly troubling and concerning
and disqualifying if they're proven true
he says he's even conceded the election
yet right Morrissey still don't know
riding his horse to the next speech I'm
not quite sure what's going I haven't
kept up to date on that when people you
know I asked this on my radio show I'm
gonna ask a knight I know when they
write in on their cards you know yes
I'll give you 25 bucks or 50 bucks or
they write a note what's the number one
thing people want done the Republican
electorate what do they want right now
I'm getting a lot of Merry Christmas
cards that's great but I always look at
them for you it is tax cuts we have to
show that we can pass a big agenda item
and govern with the majority and they
don't to see people support the
president they won't see Congress
supports presence isn't the ladder
really important support the President's
agenda support the President's agenda a
hundred percent we hear that all the
time at the RNC and it is part of why we
are having such record fundraising how
do we become the Republican Party how
can it be a National Party if every
presidential election we write off
California and New York essentially
and how does how do you change that
dynamic we're gonna be in California in
New York this year because of some of
the congressional seats that are in play
but you do have to make small strides
and I did that as Michigan chair we had
an office in Detroit it was open for
three years we never shut it down we
have to start showing up in these blue
states I was the chair of a state that
nobody thought was winnable
presidentially presidentially we want it
for the first time since 1988 we can
replicate that across the country but we
have to put resources and we've got to
take our message in and we've got to
show up and stay and showing up going to
going into hostel it's so little areas
went when Trump went to Detroit that
black church he's got to do that like
once every couple weeks go to it - he
went to Detroit and Flint are you would
you advise him to continue to do that
continue that push into minority areas
that can be helped by real economic
reform I want him to he's talking about
skilled trades he's talking about jobs
he's talking about their paychecks and
we need to show up and give our message
because Republicans have been absent for
too long and that's certainly a focus of
the Republican Party did he make you
drop your last name is he telling you
not to use your maiden name I read that
drop rebalanced story let me just tell
you there are three reasons why I have
emphasized the McDaniel a little bit
more what my husband Patrick my two kids
Abigail and Nash when I took this job
they see their mom a lot less well and
their net last name is McDaniel they
deserve for their mom to be emphasizing
that name more this is the dumbest story
we have way more important things to
talk about I mean it's just kind of fun
I don't think I'm an I like both names
but it's like I haven't yeah but I'm
using the McDaniel a little bit more cuz
I've got three people at home that are
supporting me and they deserve their
life Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
Mary we can say that again